voici raul raul est un grain de sable et
voici son histoire alors initialement
j'avais prévu de vous emmener dans plein
d'endroits hyper cool comme ça ça ou ça
ah non pas ça mais comme cette vidéo
tournée pendant le confinement et ben on
va faire avec les moyens du bord et
finalement je trouve ça encore mieux
donc en route milou on va à la plage et
le maison bras donc vous vous demandez
qui ira aussi si vous le demandez
raul est quelconque raul est plusieurs à
où les multiples en fait ramené pas
défini par sa nature mais par sa taille
il mesure entre un centième de
millimètre et 2 mm de large donc le
sable ça peut être des miettes de
n'importe quoi à houlé plusieurs c'est
pour ça qu'on vole une telle diversité
de règles sur terre même si la plupart
de semble à ça
et ça c est là et ça c'est glace beach
en californie ce sable il assez
particulier puisqu'il est d'origine
humaine
il a été créé par des années de
déversements sauvages d'ordures sur la
côte les vagues et le ressac de la mer
ont cassé et fragmenté les bouteilles de
verre qui avait parmi les déchets ce qui
a engendré ce sable très spéciale
constituée de bouts de verre nous sommes
en clair maintenant il ya plein de
touristes qui viennent sur cette plage
pour admirer ces restes de décharge à
ciel ouvert est rodée par les vagues
c'est très instagram abl et ce qui est
drôle c'est que le vert à la base il est
obtenu au fond dans du sable donc en
fait cette plage c'est du sable devenu
vert redevenu le sable on peut même
avoir des petites surprises dans le
sable certain raoul de rivière qui
tiennent de l'or c'est ce qu'on appelle
déplacèrent aurifère à ce sujet j'ai une
anecdote à vous raconter c'est une
histoire assez insolite dans les
montagnes du nord de la géorgie une
ethnie les vannes pratique leur paillage
dans les rivières du caucase depuis
toujours ils utilisent des toisons de
moutons qu'il fixe dans les cours d'eau
ou récolter les paillettes d'or qui s'y
trouvent en abondance les paillettes se
fixe dans l'haleine tandis que le reste
des minéraux poursuit son chemin dans la
rivière selon certains cette pratique
serait à l'origine du mythe jason et de
la toison d'or
et comme le rat ou les très pauvres
c'est aussi un bon réservoir pétrole ou
à gaz naturel dans certains rares cas et
quand il a enfoui en profondeur bonjour
vous auriez cinq minutes pour parler de
la méthode scientifique
désolé ces deux titres donc je mettais
tout ce qui compte au final c'est
comment on passe de ça à ça tout
commence quand raul était encore une
roche seulement à houle s'est fait érodé
sa race il a subi la pluie le vent les
vagues les racines des plantes
l'intégrale des reprises de michel
sardou par la quête united
les glaciers le gel et le chaud froid
entre le jour et la nuit ces différences
de température on dit latin est
contracté raul qui a fini par éclater
comme mon petit coeur quand j'ai appris
qu'il y aura pas de saison 52 à la série
friends pourtant les scénaristes c'était
vraiment toujours aussi bon boulot cette
petite vicieuse
c'est glisser dans les interstices de la
roche la nuit l'eau gèle à l'intérieur
de la gauche elle se dilate puisque
l'eau gagne 10 % de son volume quand
elle devient un glaçon appuyé sur les
parois de part et d'autre et et free de
la roche ou plutôt à la désagrège comme
notre espoir d'un avenir meilleur dans
une société capitaliste les morceaux
seront d'abord grossier puis de plus en
plus petit donc si on prend l'exemple du
granit
il se fait et rodez en forme de boule on
obtient donc à un chaos granitique ou
parfois un dôme comme le pain de sucre
de canne allons avec à son pied du sable
le produit de cette érosion finalement
l'eau c'est un peu comme la main géante
de la providence qui vient gratter le
granité en détache tous les petits
minéraux du coup le sam sera constitué
des mêmes minéraux que le granit quartz
feldspath et mika pour le granit ce
phénomène d'érosion s'appelle la
réalisation et ce sable là c'est une
arme en latin à oreille il a ça signifie
sable serait tout à voir avec les arènes
des romains et des férias et rien à voir
avec les années
bien sûr ce processus d'érosion il se
fait pas d'un claquement de doigts ça
prend plusieurs milliers voire millions
d'années mais c'est pas tout c'est notre
rôle est donc désert il va se faire
violenter par le vent et il finira tout
rond tout lisse et émoussés à force
d'avoir été frappée contre 7,10 copains
mais partout ailleurs la torture de raul
n'est pas fini il va pas rester là
tranquille as pogner le beigne lourds va
l'attaquer aller comme ça peste
c'est pour ça que moi vivante aucune
molécule d'eau ne touchera ni en dehors
ni en dedans
lova transporté raul dans des rivières
jusqu'à la mer mais elle va pas se
contenter de faire le taxi elle dissout
certains minéraux ce qui explique la
composition de l'eau minérale derrière
l'os et charges en minéraux en
traversant la roche et nous on la boit
et on se transforme en bébé joufflu
ça explique aussi pourquoi tu as la mer
et ça les minéraux en morceaux donc les
éléments chimiques qui les constituent
sont charriés par les rivières et arrive
dans la mer qui elle s'évapore beaucoup
les éléments chimiques que vont rester
en bas du coup ils vont se concentrer
avec une majorité de sodium et de chlore
qui une fois qu on les combine nous
donnes tu sais au final la mer est 500
fois plus salée que l'eau douce mais
c'est pas tout pour les minéraux qui ne
sont pas solubles dans l'eau la petite
passe n'a pas dit son dernier mot alors
elle les transforme
on dit qu'elle les haltères en gros ils
deviennent d'autres minéraux au gré des
réactions chimiques le plus souvent d
argile ou de la rouille c'est à dire des
oxydes de fer mais du coup c'est plus du
sable c'est des particules trop petit
pour être considéré comme du sable et
elles seront balayés par la prochaine
pluie ou la prochaine vague quoi ici par
exemple on voit comment évolue un genre
de granit au fil du temps certains
minéraux ne bouge pas ou presque alors
que d'autres vont disparaître comme
dupont ligonnès et d'autres encore
apparaît ce n'est de l'altération des
précédents comme dupont de ligonnès en
écosse après sa chirurgie esthétique
on a même un joli dia grave
le géologue raffole des diagrammes si
vous vous lancez du rhin a porté lui un
saucisson et un diagramme donc ce drame
nous dit qu'elle minéraux vous marchez
en premier et lesquels craignent des
gains l'olivine est la première à
prendre cher elle pourra donner du
quartz et de la rouille puis celle au
gîte la roulade l'habitat etc
senio 17h facilement on dit qu'ils sont
la bile les autres sont malades
c'est faux sont juste stable ou
résistants l'altération et parmi eux il
ya le mica le fais pas tu es surtout le
quartz
c'est l'un des vidéos les plus stables
qu'on connaisse en plus d'être l'un des
plus durs souvenez-vous l'échelle de
dureté et agro ce concierge preuve
d'amour tout ça et là vous vous demandez
qu'est ce qui fait qu'un minérale
résistent ou pas l'altération si si vous
vous le droit ça ça va dépendre de
l'organisation du cristal si les
attentes sont bien liés les uns aux
autres comme c'est le cas du quartz le
minéral ne craindra rien ou presque
au contraire les liaisons sont un peu
larges comme celle olivine alors l'eau
pourra s'engouffrer dans le réseau
cristallin et semer la zizanie tels les
femen au sénat
d'ailleurs ces minéraux là ça ne vous
rappelle rien
c'est ce du granit et des autres roches
issues du refroidissement du magma est
justement quand une poche de magma
refroidi pour se transformer en cailloux
c'est d'abord l'olivine qui apparaît
comme magma est chaud bouillant puis
logique
l' orne blême et caetera et le quartz an
dernier quand le magma est déjà bien
refroidi donc une fois en surface le
quartz sera plus stable parce que ça lui
rappelle globalement ces conditions de
formation il n'est pas trop dépaysé
c'est un peu comme un sudiste expatrié à
paris il va mourir de froid et va sentir
très vite mal à moins de redescendre
dans son sud ensoleillé un lyonnais et
tiendra peut-être un peu plus longtemps
à paris mais ça va quand même le
transformer et qu'ils le veuillent ou
non quoi il finira par dire des trucs
comme bonjour ans comment vas-tu chien
ou ce concert de free jazz il est
vraiment sens alors quel parisien de
souche il est bien parce que c'est ce
qu'il connaît depuis toujours il a sa
place
donc pour résumer plus on attend ou bien
plus on s'éloigne de la roche mère c'est
pareil plus le sable qu'on trouve
ressemblera à ça c'est parce que vous
croyez ça c'est du quartz pur parce
qu'en fait le reste des minéraux ce sera
fait dégradé comme un cimetière juif
dans le bas rhin
c'est l'évolution naturelle des sables
en fait ou dit plusieurs milliers
d'années naturellement tous les sables
on commence à devenir du parti donc le
quartz est un peu le raoul du futur et
puis un sale ne sait pas que des grains
qui disparaissent il peut aussi en avoir
qui apparaissent et oui pensez en
coquillages penser aux coquillages ne
pense pas assez aux coquillages fermer
les yeux respirez profondément
visualiser un coquillage la douceur de
sa robe se strient régulière
chatoyant son regard mais les feux
[Musique]
son fol espoir de se réincarner
gas le coquillage le coquillage se
retrouve aussi dans le sable tant qu'il
est broyé à ses fins ça passe c'est
considéré comme du sable du sable
d'origine biogénique du coup c'est à
dire qu'il a été fabriqué par un
organisme vivant et c'est pareil pour
les squelettes de poisson ou de plancton
entre autres organismes
techniquement c'est aussi des minéraux
des bio minéraux même et en l'occurrence
de la calcite c'est ce qu'on trouve
principalement dans les sables coquille
sinon autre exemple de sable d'origine
biogen que j'aime particulièrement
c'est le poisson perroquet à bosse qui
fait quelqu'un du sable lune et grignote
du corail mort et le bras avec les dents
qu'il au fond de la gorge pour en
extraire les algues microscopiques qui
contient et comme il digère pas le
corail il le rejette par l'anus en un
nuage de sable fin et c'est loin d'être
anecdotique chaque fois son aval jusqu'à
cinq tonnes de corail par an
on en apprend des choses ici on
s'instruit en s'amusant et là vous vous
dites oh mon dieu il d'être les coraux
faudrait l'empêcher de nuire non figurez
vous faites qui met reliques au logis
très important parce que ils nettoient
les récifs coralliens des cadavres pour
que le corail 9 puis s'installe à la
basse et en outre le sable qui rejette
aide à consolider et stabilisé de récifs
mais aussi à alimenter les plages donc
si un jour vous arpentez avec mon chat
lance une plage paradisiaque du
pacifique
souvenez vous que ce sable blanc se
moquer est peut-être passé par l'anus
d'inde poissons perroquets à bosse
maintenant du coup on peut regarder ce
qu'il ya dans ce raul que j'ai ramassé à
la plage à côté de chez moi
à l'heure qu'il est il est bien
représentatif du sable standard c'est un
peu le produit de marque distributeur
alors que les sables fanci qu'on a vu au
début ça c'est les versions de luxe
[Musique]
oh la la qu'est-ce qu'il est beau
comme prévu le sable culture du quartz
en abondance ainsi que des débris de
coquillages de la calcine il est
vraiment magnifique
[Musique]
des basques est un bon jour revenons
donc au dessus car le poppers et thomas
c'est durant et des cartes
allez-y prenait ouazar désolé donc
maintenant qu'on sait qu'il y aura ou
les questions c'est réseau cristallin on
va pouvoir voir pourquoi raul est un
héros raul est un héros parce qu'il nous
permet de faire des tas de trucs de ça à
ça en passant par ça ça ou ça ça fallait
peut-être pas raul et même la troisième
ressource la plus exploitée sur terre
après l'air l'eau et les enfants au
bangladesh tellement exploiter
qu'elle-même surexploités n'en consomme
trop par rapport à ce que les dieux de
la géologie en produise il faut
plusieurs milliers d'années pour faire
du bois où j'ai du bon raul dampmart à
ollières l échelle de la planète ou non
consommerait 40 à 50 milliards de tonnes
par an mélanger avec le gravier ça fait
18 kg par jour et par personne qui fois
que je prends en moyenne pendant cette
quarantaine il va falloir une brouette
pour vous déplacer bientôt mais y'a pas
tous les obèses ce qui concerne le plus
de sable de gravier c'est le btp pour
fabriquer du béton et du ciment
d'ailleurs la quantité de sable et de
gravier extrait de chaque année à ses
fins pourrait nous permettre de
construire un mur de 27 mètres de haut
par 27 mètres de large tout le long de
l'équateur puis en deuxième viennent les
remblais maritime saisi l'artificiel à
dubaï en toute simplicité par exemple
ont englouti au total plus de 750
millions de tonnes de raul et puis sinon
il ya singapour premier importateur et
consommateurs de sable au monde qui a
augmenté de 20% sa surface en 40 ans
comme ça bon ils ont tellement prélevé
de sable en indonésie qui sont fait
disparaître 24 il au passage mais bon ça
a que des pauvres en indonésie donc pas
vraiment de paille
non ça c'était une erreur fondamentale
d'attribution à ok c'était pas un point
godwin
non ça c'est quand tu fais un strike au
bowling hockey sera où l'on prélève dans
le lit des rivières au fond de tadla mer
ou sur le littoral ou alors on en
extrait directement dans les carrières
mais parce que le sable du désert il
n'est pas adapté à la construction trop
fins être auront quand même plutôt
ballot parce que pour le coup on en
avait pas mal en réseau et évidemment
extraire des quantités aussi mirifique
de sable pas ça a des conséquences sur
l'environnement
si vous prélevez bus
bhl dans la rivière il y en a moins qui
arrive jusqu'à la mer et comme l aigle
ou tonnes et qu'elle veut son lot de
sédiments et bah du coup elle va aller
grignoter les réserves de la plage et sa
vallée rodez et puis quand on extrait du
sablon remuer la vase on racle le fond
ça perturbe les êtres de vie qui
habitent dans les parages ça peut aussi
déstabiliser les rivières qui peuvent se
mettre accrue et plus souvent et plus
violemment en alternance avec des
périodes de sécheresse beaucoup plus
veinards qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
l'assèchement total de cours d'un bref
c'est pas franchement guinness et les
pays qui prennent le plus cher sont
surtout en asie mais aussi en afrique
qui est un peu en amérique du sud
du coup on sent dans un rapport de 2019
l'onu a dit que ça serait bien de créer
une gouvernance internationale des
ressources en sables pour l'instant
c'est un peu le far west quand même sans
parler de l'extraction illégale parce
qu'on parle carrément de mafia du sable
la moitié du sable marocains auraient
été prélevés illégalement sur leur
propre compte pour construire des hôtels
des routes et d'autres trucs pour les
touristes maroc les pays qui voyagent en
vie pour épargner raul l'onu recommande
d'économiser la ressource donc de
réfléchir à deux fois avant de faire une
île à l'effigié de stéphane bern par
exemple de chercher des alternatives et
de recycler le béton l'asphalté le vert
voilà ça c'était la touche écolo donc
pour résumer c'est quoi le sable le
sable est ce qu'on appelle un milieu
granulaire constitué de minéraux issus
de l'érosion ou de l'altération d'une
roche
parmi ces minéraux la plupart sont
dissous dans l'eau ou transformés en
d'autres minéraux comme les argiles le
seul qui résiste vraiment c'est le
quartz et c'est pour ça qu'on en
trouvera en abondance dans notre raul
house qui permet de faire des pas de
trucs chouettes host de ça ça en passant
par saha non pas ça c'est pour ça que
raul est un héros mais aéro à utiliser
avec modération puisque raul est un
héros prenant soin de lui car c'est un
héros notre rôle
c'est
quoi mais arrêté de sonner chez nous pas
le sang bleu au pardon je suis
absolument désolé on frise le
harcèlement là quand même
du coup vous aurez 5 minutes pour parler
de géologie vous connaissez claude
allègre et voilà c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo mais ne partez pas gd chose
à vous dire si je vous ai forcément
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous venger
en lit quand on la commente en partage
est là aussi pour que vos amis puissent
à leur tour s'énerver je crois que c'est
comme ça que ça marche mais non sinon
sur cette chaîne s'explique par le fait
duquel par devers moi j'étais impliqué
dans d'autres projets du reste comme le
vortex montrent qu'ils sortiront bientôt
je vous tiendrai au courant toute façon
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur les réseau
cristallin humour et surtout forte de
mes cinq abonnés j'ai décidé de me vouer
corps et âme à cette chaîne donc si tout
va bien les vidéos devraient sortir un
peu plus souvent par sommes maintenant
inch'allah comme dit mon beauf people
que j'ai recueillis lors d'un safari
voilà ces moments je vous raquette donc
si jamais vous êtes momentanément trop
riches parce que vous avez arrêté de
consommer comme des porcs n'hésitez pas
à être généreux avec l'oeuvre de charité
de votre choix sachant que la plus
robuste mans bénéfique à ce jour c'est
évidemment un mois c'est donc sur
monotype ou une typique que j'ai ouvert
pour l'occasion
merci pour moi et et voilà salut
[Musique]
mais d'un double cette vidéo
ces trente secondes les camps de faim
c'est presque réponse quatre fromages